what is your actual thoughts on Fox is
Fox what it was before has it lost its
Sizzle what is Fox cable is totally over
cable is over or Fox is over both I mean
Fox that Dominion
lawsuit okay how about that everything
everything you and all these Trump
supporters are mad at me for saying
really how do you feel now that you know
that all of your Your Heroes on Fox News
like Tucker felt the same way saying he
hates Trump with a passion this isn't
true putting all these people on knew
that Trump had lost the election saying
all that came out in Discovery um
reminder when when you get a subpoena
you have to respond Fox did it um so we
have what their texts and what their
emails were and there's no daylight
between what I say about Trump and what
they were saying about Trump off camera
you feel good now Trump supporters that
you were being lied to no that's that's
how much they respect the audience we're
just going to lie to you and give you
what whatever you want and all the
networks are doing that now um I'm I'm
friends with Lawrence O'Donnell um we
used to have dinner in La he put me on
one time he's an MSNBC Prime know people
know who he is um and it was like six
months before one of my books was coming
out and I said okay I'll do your show
but I want you to have me on when my
book comes out um you know talk about
unilateral performance
clause and he said yes absolutely he had
me on we had a great time he told me um
his mother told him it was the only time
he looked happy I mean we bickered we're
friends but he's smart I think I'm okay
um so we had a lot of fun and then he
wouldn't have me on again and why
because the audience didn't like it well
if you're going to be driven by your
audience that's why MSNBC is crazy left
that's why Fox will lie to its viewers
lie to its viewers see that's why we'll
have uh uh Stephen Schmidt last week and
the audience can get upset and next week
we'll have you on and the other side of
we'll have an athlete on and then
they're going to be confused half the
time we just like talking to people
there's something I want you to do for
me you've got to get me the clip of him
arguing with Steve Schmidt because I
can't bear to look at him I can't bear
to listen to him but if I can just see
the clip of you that will make me happy
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here